it was one a hell of a weekend for the
call of duty league
i'm talking ddos attacks causing playoff
games to be played
offline multiple emergency substitutions
and even accusations of illicit gambling
all before one of the best series in the
history
of call of duty this one was a bit of a
roller coaster
[Music]
okay so if you like new shows like this
one don't at me
you're gonna love our talk show over on
twitch at twitch.tv
the score esports called clouded every
wednesday at 1pm eastern
colin dan devin and now even josh bury
we get together and we talk all the
latest news so you can be caught up
on everything going on with esports so
make sure you go over give us a follow
and turn notifications on
now let's get back to this crazy weekend
in call of duty much like the overwatch
league the call of duty league
continued its inaugural season online
despite the covet 19 outbreak
and this past weekend marked its first
ever playoff matches
we're talking like the biggest event the
biggest prize pool in cod
history on the ultimate proving grounds
call of duty's elite converge when that
moment stares you in the face
you'll know one thing glory isn't given
glory isn't easy glory
is taken
but as things got underway well there
were some issues
the pro cog community had to deal with
something they're actually not that
unfamiliar
with going back to the days of advanced
warfare pro play online
ddos attacks and mid-match booting of
pro players
basically because the games were being
played online
hackers would go in ddos attack and boot
a pro player from a live game
at the highest level of play out there
this was pretty crazy
and in the optic versus la guerrillas
match it actually got so bad that optic
had to sub
in a different player because kenny had
been booted multiple times already in
the match
yeah they also mean i it looks like
kenny no longer in the in the server so
something happened there so they're
trying to do this four versus five right
now
i didn't see when did he drop uh it's
been about him over a minute and as you
might imagine
the pro community was pissed obviously
the competitive integrity of the games
were being called into question
and pros were asking for things like
postponing the event or boycotting it
entirely
a really long time ago in a land when
dinosaur a world when
when dinosaurs roamed the earth uh
advanced warfare was a game
and in that there was an online league
and hitting people offline
was an issue so much so to the point
where the league had to be restarted
because it was impossible to avoid
everyone's getting hit off again and
this has become an issue
to the point where now it's impacting a
4 million tournament this tournament has
a more than
4 million dollar prize pool by far
the biggest payout in the history of
call of duty so for me
those frustrated tweets you're seeing
well they kind of make sense
at minimum from twitter reports alone at
least five players
had this problem literal ddos attacks in
the middle of the playoffs
now luckily for optic the example i
showed above didn't cost them the match
but many players have speculated if they
were playing against
any team other than the lowly la
gorillas
it could have been a different story
they could close it out here slasher
peaks the edge it's all the saints
saints last man up he's been spotted
draza and tj have got to get to trade
and there it is
the kill is in for optic they're gonna
get the series win
so your activision blizzard you're
putting this situation in the middle of
the biggest tournament of all time
in your brand new league in the middle
of a global pandemic
what do you do well their quick fix
actually ended up being to start the
matches offline
that way these attackers couldn't get to
the players live
many players also started to scramble
their ip addresses to make it even more
difficult so they made that change
and everything was fine until it wasn't
on august 21st the third day of playoff
competition
fans started to notice that scores were
updating on the call of duty league
playoff website
before the matches had actually started
on stream
keep in mind activision blizzard didn't
tell anybody they were making this
change
so as far as fans were concerned these
matches were just being played live
so when the chicago huntsmen were
playing the new york sub liners and
fans could see the results of the first
two maps before the games had even
started on stream
people were a little confused and it's
obviously awkward if you're a fan right
you don't just want to see the score you
want to see the game and it gets even
more awkward when you throw gambling
into the mix this change was made pretty
quickly
they didn't exactly have time to let
vegas know so for a short while you
could
bet on a game while already knowing the
results of the first two maps
what's more is that some of the players
being targeted by the ddos attacks in
the first place
suggested that those might also be
related to betting you see the league
was hosting a special perfect
bracket challenge that awarded a hundred
thousand dollars
to anybody that had a perfect bracket
all the way through the playoffs
similar to what you know they do with
march madness and college basketball the
bracket challenge coupled with the fact
that all these attacks were happening on
hardpoint
a type of match where in the rules it's
very difficult to replay them
make this all very sketchy if you're a
hacker playing in this bracket challenge
and you wanna
you know make your hundred thousand
dollars you go and you
target your ddos attacks towards
hardpoint so you can
actually influence the results of those
matches
it's uh it's 150 total points they were
past that threshold
so basically this is to you know kind of
kind of
alleviate issues if it happens like the
start of the game is really early in the
game and
you know somebody's playing with that
unfortunately in this particular
circumstance it happens uh
happens a bit deeper but yeah uh joe it
sucks there's no way around that no way
to hide from that
uh i feel for the optic guys right now
like i said off the top
booting and ddos attacks have been a
problem multiple times in the history of
cod online pro play
so it's baffling to me that this is even
allowed to happen in the first place
now betting controversies and ddos
attacks aside
this weekend of call of duty was
miraculously able to
survive the controversies by the time
sunday rolled around and teams were
competing for their slot in
next weekend's top four matches fans
were [ __ ]
pumped for some call of duty action and
a lot of that has to do with sunday's
match that pitted the
new optic gaming against the chicago
hunts which aside from being a
highly anticipated series with two good
teams had the added drama
of pitting obviously the old face of
optics skump
against an organization that is in many
ways a shell of its former self
and what ensued was a five match
bloodbath
that peaked at more than 150 000 viewers
on youtube
that some people are calling one of the
best matches
in call of duty history trying to watch
the flank keep taking a peek for a
second get some information able to stay
alive for now and has daddy up
dj now i'm gonna push this oh my god i
have no idea how tj gets through and
finds both kills
but tj makes the play envoy gonna peek
from outside
the challenge is gonna come in scum's
gotta reload no one can finish the kill
or sees picks up two it's all gonna be
on tj now
1v1 and huntsman win it odd boy get the
kill in the 1v1
and they move on it's madness and when
the dust settled the huntsmen were able
to
just squeak out a win and earn
themselves a spot in next weekend's top
four bracket
the huntsman dallas empire atlanta phase
and london royal ravens
will all be competing for the top prize
of 1.5
million dollars and so after a week that
started with ddos attacks
complaints about the game complaints
about the rules some questionable
betting opportunities
we got one last awesome [ __ ] match of
call of duty and i do have to note that
so far
activision blizzard has released no
statement on
any of the drama over the weekend
including the ddos attacks
and some of these questionable betting
things we're talking about now while
people were stoked about that last
huntsman match
there were no shortage of choice words
on twitter this past weekend
about both the game modern warfare and
the event itself
and i personally think that seattle
serge's octane
might have won twitter for this one
i think we're here
i'm still pleased waiting bro i don't
care i will sit here this whole time
and it's gone so we actually lost the
audio for this end board when keith had
to reshoot so i'm just gonna tell you
guys the story instead
so it turns out that keith and dan
actually ran into each other in downtown
toronto on saturday and dan was telling
us that keith looked super pissed off
as it turns out keith had his tattoo
artist double book him so he had taken a
trip
all the way into downtown toronto in the
middle of a pandemic
and still couldn't get a tattoo that's
it
that's the whole story